[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists have you ever owned
an item that you wanted to declutter but
you held onto it because you might want
to pass it on to a relative in the
future
or
has anyone in your family ever passed
down a supposed heirloom to you
that you didn't want today on the public
episode of the minimalist podcast we're
talking about
generational junk
why we end up with so much stuff from
other people where it comes from and
what to do about it then this thursday
on the minimalist private podcast ryan
and i are going to discuss a new concept
that we're calling monday minimalism and
we'll look at 20 different ways to start
decluttering today you can check that
out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
because advertisements suck
so we usually start with listener
questions
but this title generational junk
we'll get to the listener questions in a
second
this title actually came from our
talented filmmaker videographer video
man and editor and so much more jordan
no more
he uh
well he had an experience recently where
he had to deal with some
generational junk and he and i were
having this conversation here at the
studio last week
and
well jordan i'll let you pick up the
story from there take it away video man
all right um
so yeah uh unfortunately
it wasn't a big surprise but my
grandmother passed away
in february
and we're in april now
and i
was inherited i inherited
her condo
but also i inherited
everything that was inside the condo
and
one of the interesting things that i
found when i was sifting through things
were bins of
not
her stuff
but not her mother's stuff
but her mother's mother's stuff
so your great great grandmother's stuff
yeah i know she was that great
she was related
keep my grandmother's name i'm just
kidding
keep my great great grandmother's name
no i
i found a stack of yearbooks
that go back to 1907.
oh my goodness it tripped me because i
was in high school in 2007
and i saw the the yearbook had you know
zero seven
and i was like wait and then i open it
and it's all these black and white
photos of people looking like you know
tin type photos yeah from the old west
basically you know oh wow and
i realized that these are from grand
rapids iowa or cedar rapids iowa these
all go back
to the farmhouse
that my family like bought when they
came back on the mayflower or whatever
you know what i mean like yeah yeah yeah
because the mayflower landed around
somewhere in 1907 right yeah yeah i have
a really keen understanding of american
history yeah no that's wow that's great
that would be hard
yeah that would that would be hard for
me to let go of man like there there you
have all that yeah these history books
essentially of your family dude yeah
that's crazy all right so how did you
approach it well you set them on fire
you're like i'm a minimalist so i'm
burning them
i mean my i here's the problem
is it's not just me
that this is the complicated nature of
the problem of of having a family and
being inherited uh inheriting
lots of stuff like this especially the
older older stuff like that it's there's
yeah there's piles of junk this place
she was my grandmother was a hoarder
so there's just stuff that you get rid
of but these books and things it's like
i have to talk to everyone in the family
and there's kind of a lot of like do you
want this do you want that my initial
instinct is give it to the library or
the history museum in iowa like
i think those books are old yeah yeah
yeah i think i think one of the problems
we run into here jordan and anyone else
who's listening to this is
when you inherit things like this you
inherit some family heirlooms some
sentimental items some things
that are valuable to you and your family
unfortunately when you inherit
hundreds of thousands of things from
someone who was a hoarder or a
borderline hoarder or just a collector
of stuff quite often many of those
things get in the way and we don't know
what to do and so
you'll find that there were some things
you really
find useful or valuable or sentimental
that you want to keep
but because you have so many things
they're watered down or even you don't
even know which things you want to keep
because you're overwhelmed with this
generational junk hmm
yeah um
yeah i was going to say about about
all of the
i lost my train of thought
well that's all right man i'm that
overwhelmed by all this generous
generational junk yeah well yeah i'm
curious like because
there is a certain responsibility i
would feel as well coming across all
this to go to my family and be like hey
yeah if they're all the grandma or
great-great-grandma or whatever had all
this stuff what do we do with it so did
your family did they give you permission
to let it go did they like tell you you
needed to hold on to it did they take
some stuff like how did they
well i um
i was when when everyone initially found
out that she had passed i found out all
right i read i heard from about five
different people about very specific
little things
here's the problem
i don't know where all those little
specific things are oh yeah so now i'm
searching for needles in the haystack
uh and on the way
i keep finding things like these books
like i found a coin collection
and i was telling you about the coin
collection too some of them might be
worth like 10 grand a piece a coin so
i'm like
now i'm getting i'm starting to have
this crazy amount of piles
of things that i'm like i don't know if
i want to get rid of these yeah because
i might there might actually knowing
something being uh you know doing the
research i'm like oh those might be
worth something but now it's weighing me
down yeah because i live in a you know
one bedroom apartment in l.a right and i
brought some of that stuff back and i'm
like geez
you could have brought all of it back
you simply don't have the space for it
yeah and it's hard to sort through while
it's there because there's so much stuff
like i remember when i was dealing with
my mom's stuff and i wrote about this
and everything that remains like just
dealing with
the it took me 12 days to just
non-stop like all day
12 days and she wasn't really a hoarder
the way you're describing it just all
day you know five six seven eight nine
hours a day
going through those things sorting
through them and eventually finding a
system to get rid of a lot of this
generational junk and so that's what i
want to talk about today
before we get to our
questions from the audience jordan is
there anything else you want to add to
the story
oh yeah so i i will finish up with um
i was gesturing uh that
that
when
at a certain point
i
was going sifting through this stuff and
i had i had a friend helping me
with you know throwing things away
and at a certain point i'm like okay i'm
just gonna call
like you did you know in the documentary
the initial story of the minimalist the
founding story
uh i just called two guys in a truck
and i said come and take these big
things
so they took
uh
i think it was nine
like old
50's era dressers that are just heavy
they took nine and then three beds three
mattresses three frames
and the crazy part is when they got rid
of that stuff
i looked around in the apartment i'm
like i feel like there's more stuff in
here because underneath all of those and
inside of them was just little trinkets
and then so the piles got bigger yeah
the the things behind our things are
within our things so as we start to get
rid of the things it exposes more
things and you realize like oh this is
this is rotten in many ways this whole
scenario it's like when you see a little
bit of black mold on the outside of a
wall you know
what's behind that wall yeah is a
disaster and the same thing is true with
this generational junk which we're going
to talk about now and also on the
maximal episode this thursday ryan we
have some of our audience some of our
kind patrons have talked about some of
their generational junk that they're
dealing with so we'll have some
additional questions over there
on thursday as well in addition to those
20 ways to start decluttering today and
monday minimalism so ruth has a question
for us how do you tell your relatives
that you don't want their generational
junk is there a diplomatic way to say no
when emotions are involved is there a
diplomatic way
maybe the the better context instead of
diplomatic is is there a compassionate
way to say no
and i think like whenever uh i don't
know whenever a family member offers me
something
yeah that i know that i'm not going to
use like i i don't come at it from i'm a
minimalist i can't do that i come at it
from a
compassionate hey this isn't gonna i
know this means a lot to you but it
doesn't mean a lot to me uh-huh it's
like you know when my oma tried to give
me that paperweight god love her
it was like i could tell it meant a lot
to her it was still in the box and she's
like oh yeah you're a writer so you must
there must be papers everywhere you need
a paperweight now did remind me did she
buy that paperweight for you or was it
something she had had for a long time
something she just had for a long time
waiting for the perfect person to give
it to waiting to weigh
you
right or was a literal paperweight yes
but yeah i mean like i can i can only
speak to my experience with um
you know with with with that situation
happening to me and when that situation
happened to me i said omar i love you
i can tell that you are giving me this
because you care for me you want to help
me you want to add value to my life
you're trying to make me uh happier more
organized i said um in order for me to
be more organized and happier i actually
can't take that because i don't really
have a use for that it'll just sit there
and be a
literal paperweight on no papers yes and
then she finally understood after you
explained it to me yeah she was like oh
okay i said if you want though i can
find it a really good home
he was like yeah that would be good can
you find a good home for me i said sure
so then i donated it yeah and i'm sure
someone bought that paperwork and
they're very happy with it
jordan oh yeah i was gonna say i could i
could chime in on uh this question from
the really personal standpoint i was
really close with my grandma
and
from her standpoint of all of this
collecting of stuff
it wasn't about she wasn't hoarding for
herself
she thought she was coming at it from a
a
uh helpful for the family like
perspective she
she kept like collecting things that she
thought that we would want and need in
the future
so a lot of like weird stuff there was
duplicates and duplicates of things i
threw away like
15 different types of coffee makers like
because over time she's like you know
older lady yeah she's she knows i like
coffee she keeps getting coffee makers
right
that's a good deal in the coffee yeah
see this is a dylan coffee maker this is
mistaking the tool
for the function of the tool right
if the more if you buy a bag of hammers
it doesn't make you a better carpenter
it simply weighs you down the same is
true if you're ryan and i own a coffee
shop imagine well you know what ryan we
need 18 espresso machines right no they
would just get in the way of making
coffee right which is actually what we
want to do and so quite often we mistake
these tools
as
inherently valuable but the value is in
what we do
with those tools now ruth
i want to
caution you that emotion is always going
to be involved in these things if it
wasn't
then compassion wouldn't even be
required right and they wouldn't be
sentimental yes exactly a sentimental
item is sentimental because of the
emotion we associate with it and that's
what if some when one of ryan's family
members passed away and they left him
some things they maybe some of those
things may be sentimental to him they
would not have the same sentimental
meaning to me because i don't have the
same emotional attachment to those
things attachment isn't wrong it isn't
bad but understanding the clinging
nature of our attachment
well and our clinging nature to the
outcomes that we want here
is something that often makes us
miserable so ruth how do we have this
conversation well tony robbins says it's
better to kill godzilla when he's a baby
than when he's taking over the city
right
and jordan unfortunately had to wait
until godzilla was taking over his city
right it already
subsumed
his grandma's city so to speak and yeah
and in the wake of that disaster sort of
left behind a lot of things some of
which jordan will find immense value in
but the whole experience becomes much
less valuable
when
well when you have to deal with a lot of
the junk that's in the way yeah
let's move on to our callers if you have
a question or comment for our podcast
give us a call 406 219 7839 or email a
voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists.com it looks like brandon in
minneapolis has a question for us i'm a
pack rat
and i come from a long line of pack
rattery
and i would say it goes back
you know at least three generations as
many generations as i have ever known
probably more
so the last few years my wife and i
have been able to
take the steps and really
get the ball rolling on simplifying our
own lives
but now
i really worry about my parents because
in the past few years
a few of my grandparents have passed
away and moved on
and my parents
just because of the situation they are
going to have to
deal
with everything not just
their own things but my grandparents
things as well this includes
houses
garages
storage sheds and even an entire ranch
just filled with clutter
so it's an overwhelming task and i
you know i've tried to to help out where
i can um
but at this point it's
i don't know that it's really welcome
and
so on top of it being frustrating it's
it's a very emotional experience because
not only are my parents dealing
with
their own possessions that they've
acquired but now
they have to deal with
basically
you know
several lifetimes coming together
so my one remaining grandmother
she
she's dealing with alzheimer's and
um so she's been living
and
my parents have decided that it would be
best for her to finish out her time here
if they were all to move back to her
house and so they're going to be
combining those two households which
already they're carrying a lot of things
so
one of you said
you mentioned that
sometimes it's our job to brainwash our
kids
and i was wondering if you had any
thoughts or tips on
possibly brainwashing our parents
or others um
you know that just mean that much to us
[Laughter]
i don't remember saying brainwashed this
sounds like something ryan would say
jokingly ingest yeah right he doesn't
actually mean to brainwash your kids and
i know i can tell from the spirit of
brandon's question you're approaching
this in a way that it's a really
difficult subject and so you're bringing
some levity into it brandon i really
appreciate that because it's
overwhelming and before we started
recording this we're doing a live stream
with our patrons here shout out to the
live stream leave your uh comments and
questions in the chat we'll get to them
as soon as we can but podcast sean was
talking about
when his grandmother died in 2013
he realized that he was burdened by a
lot of her stuff she didn't realize he
was going to be burdened by in fact she
was holding on to a lot of these things
clinging to these things so that shawn
and his family and his extended family
would have access to them not knowing
that he might be burdened by them but
sean what was the outcome
when you finally had to start dealing
with her stuff what did you realize
well
i should clarify too it was actually
2014 when she passed but my father
passed in 2013. so it's like back to
back and my dad and her
um
kind of like you i mean had
were highly organized this was really
clean they were clean fastidiously clean
people
just did a really good job at hiding
just how much stuff they had
and packing this stuff away
and so yeah that's the thing we did not
really realize with my grandmother
because she was by herself at this point
when she passed
and when we went in there and started
cleaning that house out and getting it
prepped you know to sell
all i could think to myself and this is
before we really worked together as you
know as part of the minimalist team that
was until you know late 2014 early 2015
um but i kept thinking to myself as i'm
going through and finding another thing
and another thing and another thing and
just deeper and deeper right and things
that are obviously brand new that she
completely forgot about
i thought oh man this is so
much
work
i don't want to do this to my kids
i don't want to do this to any of my
survivors i don't want them to go
through my stuff and be the same way
right but just feeling that burden and
putting that burden on someone else and
they don't i i'm sure she wasn't
thinking that right i mean she came from
a generation of growing up in the
depression and they were thinking oh i
better say this i'm probably gonna need
it later yeah or somebody's gonna need
it later 100
yeah but well it's interesting because
sean came to that conclusion himself
through experiencing going through his
his relatives uh who have passed like
going through their things
and that is that's the only
brainwashing i'm joking and doing air
quotes that's going to be very clear
right now to who people who aren't
watching this
we're actually going to have on the
maximum episode this week we're going to
have someone who is accusing us of being
very cult-like so oh yeah that would be
fun yeah i uh
we i think we are a little cultish after
talking to amanda montal i mean we all
belong to some sort of cult anyway
um yeah so
so yeah uh yeah i get it brainwashing
comes along with uh with being in a cult
um but but look sean brainwashed himself
essentially
that's what happened yes and you know
for us to sit here and be like well
here's how here's how you can manipulate
your relatives
into getting rid of their stuff like
that
josh and i are not um
we're not encouraging you to manipulate
we're not encouraging you to brainwash
the only thing that josh and i really
are encouraging people to do in this
situation like this is is to be
supportive and that's the only way you
can really get through
uh to anyone in this type of situation
it's how can you help them
and and when they ask for help then be
at the ready to help them uh
i mean i i've got relatives who and and
you know
mariah has relatives who are uh who hold
on to stuff and like i don't go to their
house and judge them
um i don't try to brainwash them um some
of them have asked for help and then
i'll give them some ideas and and try to
help them out but but there is no
brainwashing in this the the no one
likes to be manipulated
so um so yeah it's this is more of a
matter of how can you support your
relatives how can you be compassionate
towards your relatives and then it's not
even nudging them it's more about just
being there when they are asked for help
like be ready to help them i agree that
we don't want to brainwash anyone right
however i understand where he's coming
from i need to convey this so i'm not
burdened by this stuff and so
instead of convincing them
that they have too much stuff because
convincing doesn't work either a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still and that
certainly goes for your parents
what i'll say here is
you can help them understand
right now they don't understand that
this stuff
is a burden or if they do
they don't understand the gravity of
that burden they might realize like oh
yeah it's a little bit of stuff they'll
have to sort through it but it's better
for the whole family if we hold on to
these things that's the story they're
telling themselves but if you ask them
some very pointed
compassionate kind questions i feel for
you and where you are right now brandon
because you don't want to be burdened by
these things and so i wouldn't go to it
in a way that's saying no no no
i would go to in a way that helps them
understand that if they hold on to too
many things what they're doing is
weighing your future self down so let's
talk practically what you can do you can
tell them hey there are some things that
you own right now that i would love to
inherit that's how you say yes
to them holding on to some stuff so
don't just hop in there and this goes to
ruth and her question earlier as well
you don't want to just hop in there and
say no no no you walk out of the house
you look at all the stuff no to that no
to that no no no no no no no no no i
don't want your stuff
okay
that's not helpful but what if you go to
the house say oh wow look at these 12
things i would really like to hold on to
that and that and that
hey what about this dresser no i don't i
have a use for that personally but
someone else might find value in it
let's see if anyone else in the family
is interested in that i was talking to
my wife about this just yesterday
i said when your parents pass away you
know thankfully they're really healthy
and they'll be here for a long time
but
eventually they'll we all die and there
will be some stuff
how is your family going to handle that
are they going to feel compelled to give
it all to you
she said no i think some of my family
will find value in many of those things
but we're not going to fight over those
things
but we're also not going to force other
people to take the things that we don't
want yeah and i thought that was a
really mature perspective here because
really when we're talking about
inheriting there are some things we want
to inherit sure but most of the things
we have no desire
to be burdened by in the first place so
you can set that expectation right now
by saying yes to the things you know you
want and allowing them to pass on the
other things that someone else will get
value from because just because you're
not going to get value from the thing
doesn't mean that someone else won't get
value from it and they might even get
value from it now so letting go of it
right now or this year or soon will mean
it's not taking up space not collecting
dust
not being treated like a dead thing in a
mausoleum it can have a new life in
someone else's house and how freeing is
that
yeah i just want to pipe in real quick
because this reminded me as you were
talking about this
when i was in grad school for education
i took an ed site course
and in ed psych one of the things they
say is you don't want to tell students
this is how we learn as humans
don't tell students what you don't want
them to do
emphasize what you want them to do
emphasize the positive behavior
incentivize don't punish
yeah 100 what a great point hey brandon
i'd love to send you two things one is
well
tomorrow and the next day so the uh
tuesday wednesday thursday
on april 27th and 28th where we have the
last two tour stops and the love people
use things tour yeah in america we're
gonna be in chicago and minneapolis i'd
love to give you a couple tickets or
maybe even a few extra tickets if you'd
like maybe you can bring the family with
you brandon to our minneapolis event
we'll be in chicago in minneapolis
finishing the american version of the
love people use things tour ryan gives a
talk about minimalism i'll do a reading
from our book love people use things and
we'll do a live version of the
minimalist podcast in your city there
are still a few tickets left for both
cities you can find those at
theminimalists.com
tour we also have a couple stops in
canada scheduled for later this year in
toronto and vancouver if you'd like and
you can find all of our previous tour
stops there as well the minimalists.com
tour and while we're at it and we're
talking about dealing with
dead people's stuff
my mom died that was really the
beginning of
of all of this for us the minimalism
thing and i wrote about that journey in
detail
in our second book everything that
remains so if you like our podcast i
think you'll enjoy the audiobook version
of everything that remains or podcast
shawn can reach out to you and get you a
ebook or book book of everything that
remains if you'd like we'll tune into
the live stream really quick we've got a
couple questions here what do you got
for us we have a question from mike my
mother is 60 now and is wanting to hand
down so many things that mean a lot to
her but don't mean anything to me how
can i support her without absorbing her
stuff
um
yeah that's it's
it's hard to look at someone and say hey
i know that that means something to you
but that doesn't really have any
sentimental meaning for me
um i i go back to the compassion piece
of it it's like how can you be
compassionate with with your
six-year-old mother and say hey thank
you for the sentiment
um
i don't really
have a place for that in my home
but you know maybe i could find it a
good home if you really if it means a
lot to you i could find you know someone
else who it might mean a lot too
but yeah it's never easy to say no
but i'll tell you the
the difficulty of saying no upfront
is a lot easier to deal with than the
later difficulty of saying yes to
everything right right because if we say
yes to everything all of a sudden we're
burdened by a heap of things we wish we
would have said no to here's what i'll
say mike and first off thank you for
being a patreon supporter and i'm sorry
that
you feel the sort of future burden of
these things and i totally get it man
here's what i'll say if it's a thing or
a handful of things that's probably
not the problem the problem is when it
becomes a pattern of things
a
entire home full of things a room full
of things a thing full of things a
dresser that has more things in it right
all of these things that are essentially
paperweights in our lives and as you
alluded to ryan sometimes someone will
impart a meaning to something and they
think that meaning is intrinsic to the
thing and i get why it feels like that
thing is incredibly meaningful but for
mike
it doesn't have an inherent meaning
right for him it is a piece of junk and
so the
compassionate way is not to say hey this
has no meaning
because then it feels like a judgment it
feels like an affront
it feels as though
i'm saying you're wrong
for
finding meaning
in that thing yeah instead you can
simply say that hey i don't have any
particular use for that thing i don't
have any room for that thing
and i recognize that it's incredibly
meaningful
for you
and if you say that i see you is what
we're saying what is love
to love someone is to see them for who
they are and part of who they are is
the meaning they give to things or
relationships or experiences
seeing the whole version of that person
i see you i see that that thing
is meaningful to you and that's okay
it's also okay that i don't associate
the same meaning to that thing but i
recognize that it's added tremendous
value to your life and i have no
judgment about that whatsoever and mike
it is completely possible to say no
and
still show them gratitude for you know
their their sentiment behind what
they're trying to do i mean
uh just as josh is saying i mean
giving them the gratitude is showing
them like hey i i respect you i i see
where you're coming from
um thank you but no thank you yes yeah
yeah and you can thank them in a way
that is sincere yeah that is genuine
that is authentic
and you can see them and you can ask
them about it i think one of the other
ways to approach this is
say your mom has these five things that
are really sentimental mm-hmm ever talk
about those things
record her talking about those things
yeah i can tell you our friend max
lugovir he's working on a new
documentary when his mom died
he recorded so many of
the end-of-life conversations he had
with her over the last few years of her
life
and man i wish i would have done that
with my mom
as opposed to having
an apartment full of stuff
i could have had
these
documented conversations with her i
essentially could have done one-on-one
podcasts before
i knew what podcasts even were
i could have done that with her and that
would have been so much more meaningful
to me
than
holding on to her queen anne bed or some
silverware or some doilies
right
so
mike thanks again shout out to the live
stream we'll get to more of your
questions on the maximal episode but
right now ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place
minimalmaxims.com looks like we have a
question here from ann
i'm trying to get rid of a family
antique but a local museum isn't
interested and no other relatives want
it how do i let go of a piece of my
family's history
jordan brought this up earlier with
respect to many times we can get rid of
the things
by giving them to a curator so the
yearbooks great example of that your
local library might really want those
yearbooks in fact your local library
might want the hundreds or thousands of
books that your grandma held on to they
may have a use for many of them and even
if they don't have a specific use there
their
larger library system might have a use
for them and even then if they don't
have a use for one of the books or 100
of the books
they are better equipped to dispose of
those books after sorting through them
than you personally disposing of those
things there are many charities that are
able to do the same thing local goodwill
i know goodwill is a giant organization
but many of their or all of their sort
of satellite locations are individual
community-based centers
that help the local community so by
giving them things that they are able to
repurpose and sell not all of them
they're able to repurpose and sell but
giving them things that they can sell
actually helps your local community
keeping those things in a basement or a
storage locker helps no one at all but
ann i have a pithy answer for you that i
like to talk about
letting go of excess helps us hold on to
what's important
now danny and i were having this
conversation
earlier
that um sometimes if we renounce
something we're forever tied to it
that's what anthony demelo says
and so anytime we're saying no no no no
excess stuff i want no material
possessions well now i'm
that's a type of consumerism it's like
inverted consumerism in a way right
before i was so tied to my stuff because
i wanted more i wanted the gold watch i
wanted the luxury car i wanted the big
house i wanted more toilets than people
i wanted all of the stuff and so i was
so tied to it it was complex i was
interwoven into the stuff
and now
the desire to renounce the stuff
now ties me to the stuff that i get
dragged by the renunciation of it yeah i
was getting dragged by the stuff before
now i get dragged by the stuff now and
so we can hold on to things
without clinging to the things
we can hold on
to the things we get value from so if
there's someone in your family
or they have a family antique they want
to pass down
you can hold on to it if you get value
from it but a willingness to let go
means that you're not renouncing it but
you can give it up at any time you're no
longer attached to it
it's the analogy
of
climbing the monkey bars
and in order to move on you have to let
go
but you also
just as importantly have to be able to
hold on
if my daughter
can only hold on to the monkey bars
she's stuck she can't go anywhere
but if she can't hold on at all
well then she just slips off and she
falls and she hurts herself
the key is to be able to hold on and
then let go and then hold on and then
let go and then hold on and let go
that's how we get through life
yeah man oh my pithy answer is this you
needn't own an object to experience it
so
you've got a sentimental thing a piece
of your family's history
um
yeah i love the idea of uh
you know maybe taking a picture of it
and then yeah recording
you know a family member talking about
that piece
you can still experience that history
you don't have to own the object to
experience the history you know it's
interesting that the question that
they're asking here it's a difficult one
i don't
want to hold on to it
uh
and i only want to let it go if
oh and it's like conditional yeah it's
conditional which
isn't necessarily bad or anything like
that's not a value judgment it's just it
just is
and the way it is with those
parameters with that with that context
it's going to be very difficult to let
go of it so
um
you called one local place they said no
great um call some antique shops see if
they're willing to you know maybe sell
it or have it on consignment it sounds
like you want to find it a really good
home you can do that
uh but it is gonna it's gonna take a lot
of work to find that that thing a good
home
so um
yeah it's up to you on how much work you
want to put into it but yeah i mean
there's an either or here i don't want
to let go of it and the museum doesn't
want it so now what it's like well
that's
that's those are two really bad options
you have to look for more options it's
almost like you're accepting defeat yeah
it's uh i've tried everything really
named everything right exactly well i
did these two things over and over and
over right and i'm not saying that ann
did that but quite often we feel like
we've tried everything because we did
put an effort for a few hours yes and it
sucked because we got rejected and they
said no and i'm sorry they said no to
you ann but the good news is there's
more than two or three options yeah and
the truth is if we have tried everything
we would have gotten the result we
wanted yeah and because everything means
i'm willing to keep trying until i get
the result that i want yeah before we
move on to some listener comments and
tips
let's move on to our right here right
now segment ryan this is one thing going
on in the life of the minimalist
actually i got two this week i got an
update about the schools that we are
providing curriculum to so ryan and i we
decided to
support 100 students personally but then
our hometown dayton ohio
we said hey we want to teach every kid
financial literacy the foundations of
personal finance we want to help every
kid in and around dayton ohio
stay out of debt so every middle
schooler every high schooler and you can
contribute to that at theminimalists.com
education ryan and i contributed our own
money to fund the first 100 students is
25
for a middle school student 45 for a
high school student up until right now
that was only available for people to
donate in the united states but now
anyone worldwide we found out about 30
of the people who go to the page they're
international people were like hey i'm
in the uk or i'm in australia or i'm in
brazil and i want to contribute to this
wonderful cause i haven't been able to
well now you can same webpage the
minimalists.com education you can find
all the details over there you can help
us help some kids stay out of debt and
not borrow from their future you can do
that whether you're in dayton you're
anywhere in north america or you're
anywhere in the world the
minimalists.com
education
and by the way we're going to be on the
dave ramsey show
uh next week i believe or a couple weeks
from now you can stop in and say hi to
us i think there's you have to put a
link to this in the show notes sean they
have to like announce they're gonna come
there it's free to show up we'll give
out hugs and all that other fun stuff
but dave ramsey they you can come and
like they have a whole lobby there where
you can watch the show live so every day
they have like 50 to 60 70 80 90 100
people show up and watch the ramsay show
live we'll be there on monday may 9th
we'll put a link in the show notes if
you want to attend that it is free to
attend and uh real quick one other thing
i have a writing class called how to
write better and we just started an
instagram account for how to write
better with some writing tips over there
some free writing tips it's just at how
to write better we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well
also i've got a free
book that you can download called 15
ways to write better you can find that
over at howtorightbetter.org
alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi josh and ryan my name is perry i'm
calling in response to christina from
the neo-minimalism podcast
one way that i've found to introduce
friction to online buying is with
passwords so i will either just delete
all of the saved passwords in my
computer or phone or i will change the
password on a site and i'll write it
down and put it someplace where i have
to actually go get it if i want to buy
something from that website so that way
i have to really want to
buy something otherwise i go to sign in
and i'm just like
no way this is too much work so that's a
really easy way to prevent yourself from
impulse buying
hi my name is theresa and i'm calling
from indianapolis and i just found your
podcast so i'm going through them
randomly and this is about podcast
number 92.
somebody mentioned they had a lot of
papers and they mentioned medical
i just retired from working in medical
records in an oncology office please
please obtain and keep your own medical
records
scan them into a secure file the law
only requires medical facilities to keep
those for seven years
and if a doctor can't verify your
previous diagnosis and treatment it
could affect your current treatment
and
treatment plan so please take care of
your medical records
make them available for your next doctor
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment one more thing it's
the end of the month that means a brand
new month is right around the corner
it's time for the 30 day
minimalism game you can download a free
calendar over on our website
theminimalists.com
game over there you can find all the
details it's a free game to play you
partner up with someone a friend a
family member a co-worker
a grandmother immortal enemy
or an immortal enemy
what if your grandma is your
immortal enemy
sounds like it's going to be a fun game
[Music]
anyway the beginning of the month you
partner up with your grandma your cousin
your mother your spouse a co-worker etc
and you both agree to get rid of some
stuff we know that decluttering can be a
bit boring a bit drab a bit uh i don't
want to clean out my closet today i
totally get that so ryan and i found a
way to make it a bit more fun we call it
the 30-day minimalism game here's how it
works as soon as you partner up with
someone on the first day you each get
rid of one item now before that you've
already made a bet you've bet a hundred
dollars a thousand dollars a million
dollars maybe it's just a movie yeah or
maybe i'll do the laundry for you this
week people are going to movies these
days right i mean movies still exist
okay
is it are movie theater still around
yes indeed i was at one recently oh man
yeah and so
you partner up with someone you make a
friendly wager for a dollar or a meal or
laundry etc
and first day of the month you each get
rid of one item second day of the month
two items third day of the month three
items so forth and so on starts off
really easy to get you that momentum you
need to let go however i found around
day 12 is when this really starts to get
difficult because like man i just got
rid of 11 things yesterday and then
today i have to get rid of 12 things and
wait a minute tomorrow after 13 things
and you keep going whoever goes the
longest wins
if you both make it to the end of the
month then you've both won because
you've gotten rid of nearly 500 items
and that is an amazing start now we've
had some people in our minimalist.org
meetup groups ryan they have
kept it going for many months oh yeah
some people though i'm on day 34 35 36
or one of my favorite ways to do is i
just start over that's right day one now
it's one more item right and you keep
the pattern of letting go
going the minimalists.com
game if you want to download the free
calendar that you can print out it
actually keeps a tally of how many
things you've gotten rid of throughout
the month
uh ryan before the added value segment
here's a lovely testimonial from one of
our kind patreon supporters one of my
favorites here this one's from catherine
she said this episode calendar clutter
will go down as one of my favorite
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast so we did a calendar clutter
episode we talked about how we are so
eager to clutter our calendars and say
yes yes yes yes yes until it's making us
miserable that was an outstanding
episode i really enjoyed it she goes on
to say every minute was punctuated with
nuggets of wisdom about time obligation
how to find joy and how being busy can
become an excuse
i will be listening to this private
episode many more times
wow catherine thank you so much thank
you for our added value segment this
week ryan i was trying to decide between
i have a a rather bipolar sort of
taste in music so i was driving in today
listening to the new 4-2 doug and estg
album yes don't worry danny i'm not
going to that's not going to be our
added value today
it's like a sneaky extra added value for
folks who want to dive into that
i was trying to get hyped this morning
before the podcast
but in the evenings i really like to
calm down and there's this new
album i've been listening to by jordan
kritz
the
genre is
classical crossover music
i don't really know what that means me
either but it's like it just feels like
updated classical music oh okay
atmospheric sort of the album is called
novella and the first track is the title
track so we'll play you out today with
novella from jordan crits by the way we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like what are some things you
can say to help encourage your aging
parents to declutter with you while they
are still alive
what should i do with my mom's ashes
talk about what ryan and i did with my
mom's ashes
[Laughter]
your mom would have appreciated it oh
totally
were there any generational items you
gave away that you regretted
getting rid of and what are 20 different
ways to start decluttering today plus a
million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalists to subscribe and get
your personal link so that our weekly
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our community
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalist and if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at
theminimalists.com you just enter your
email address right there at the top
we'll get you on the mailing list on
behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown podcast peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn if you leave
here today with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it